Hello, beautiful nerds. For the next couple of weeks, we're going to be airing a new series we're producing in collaboration with Campside Media. We're calling it service request, and it's hosted by longtime 99PI producer and editor Delaney Hall. It's a fun and joyful and detailed deep dive into stories about infrastructure. We're looking at the nuts and bolts of how it actually works and the people who maintain it. I am very excited for you to hear it and also to get involved because we will be taking your questions about. about infrastructure and answering them in future episodes. Here's our first story.
大家好，各位出色的极客。在接下来的几周里，我们将播出与 Campside Media 合作制作的一个全新系列节目。我们称之为“服务请求”（Service Request），由长期的 99PI 制作人兼剪辑师德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）主持。这是一个有趣、欢乐且深入探讨基础设施故事的节目。我们将探讨其实际运作的核与栓，以及维护这些基础设施的人们。我非常高兴你们能听到这个节目，并且也希望你们能参与进来，因为我们将收集你们关于基础设施的问题，并在未来的节目中回答它们。以下是我们的第一个故事。
I guess to start, just tell me about your experience with Mr. Softie. Oh, Mr. Softie. Mr. Frikin Softie, Bain of my existence. This is Christopher Johnson. He's a supervising producer at 99% Invisible. And one of the first things I learned about him when we started working together was that he hated ice cream trucks. That fucking jingle comes along and it's like, oh my God, that kill me now. Dun-na-na-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da. It's the end of the song that's just like taunting you because you know it's going to start again. About five or six years ago, COVID was just starting to hit and Christopher was spending a lot of time locked down at home.
我想从头开始，先跟我讲讲你对“软冰淇淋先生”（Mr. Softie）的经历。哦，“软冰淇淋先生”。该死的“软冰淇淋先生”，我生命中的克星。这是克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）。他是《99%无形》（99% Invisible）的监督制作人。当我和他开始共事时，我了解到关于他的第一件事就是他讨厌冰淇淋车。那个该死的叮咚音乐一响起来，就好像，哦天哪，现在就杀了我吧。咚-纳-纳-达-达-达-达-达-达-达-达-达。那是歌曲的结尾，就像是在嘲弄你，因为你知道它马上又要重新开始了。大约五六年前，新冠疫情刚开始蔓延，克里斯托弗花了很多时间隔离在家。
He'd just moved into an apartment in Washington Heights, a neighborhood at the very top of Manhattan. And he was up on the 12th floor, high enough that he did not think he'd be dealing with a ton of street noise. But then the next day, and the next day, and the next day, and the next day, I'm hearing Mr. Softie pull up 12, 13 stories down, park on the corner, wait for the kids, I guess. And there are multiple Mr. Softies. It's like there's one like two blocks down.
他刚搬进华盛顿高地（Washington Heights）的一间公寓，那是曼哈顿最顶端的一个社区。他住在12楼，足够高了，以至于他认为自己不会应对太多的街道噪音。但接着第二天、又一天、再一天、又一天，我听到“软冰淇淋先生”在12、13层楼的高度下停了下来，停在街角，我想是在等孩子们。而且“软冰淇淋先生”不止一辆。就像两个街区外还有一辆。
And because I'm high, so high up, I can hear the one two blocks down, the one it's just downstairs, the one it's a couple of blocks behind me. And they're just, it feels like at a certain point, I'm being trolled by Mr. Softie. After weeks of this, Christopher got so fed up that he took action. He decided to call 311. 311 is a hotline that provides quick and easy access to all the information you might want about city services. It's also the place where people often go to complain. And as Christopher interacted with 311, trying to solve this Mr. Softie problem, he started to wonder, how in the world does the city keep track of all of these calls?
而且因为我住得很高，非常高，我能听到两个街区外的那个，楼下刚好的那个，我身后几个街区的那个。它们只是，在某个时刻感觉我被“软冰淇淋先生”给恶心到了。在经历了数周这样的情况后，克里斯托弗忍无可忍，采取了行动。他决定拨打 311。311 是一个热线电话，可以快速、轻松地获取你可能想要了解的所有关于城市服务的各类信息。它也是人们经常去抱怨的地方。随着克里斯托弗与 311 的互动、试图解决这个“软冰淇淋先生”的问题时，他开始好奇，这座城市到底是如何记录所有这些电话的？
Because New York City, there's what, 9 million people. They're taking calls and fire from all different directions across all the boroughs, like the smallest complaints, giant complaints. how on earth can they respond and keep track of all of that? I'm Delaney Hall and this is service request, a new show from 99% Invisible and Campside Media. We're interested in the vast and hidden machinery of modern life, the pipes, the wires, the tubes and tunnels beneath your feet.
因为纽约市有，什么，900万人口。他们从各个区的所有不同方向接听来自各方的电话和火警，比如最小的投诉、巨大的投诉，他们到底怎么才能应付并记录所有这一切？我是德兰妮·霍尔，这里是“服务请求”，这是来自《99%无形》和 Campside Media 的全新节目。我们对现代生活庞大而隐秘的机械装置、你脚下的管道、电线、管子和隧道很感兴趣。
Basically, all the infrastructure that no one really thinks about until something goes wrong. When something in your city breaks, like a busted streetlight or a pothole, you can call 311, file a report, and the city hopefully fixes it. But when you want to understand how your city actually works, that's where this show comes in. Think of us as the 311 of podcasting. We want you to send us your questions about infrastructure, and then we will investigate them and hopefully figure out the answers. For our very first episode, we have this service request from Christopher. How does 311 actually work?
基本上，就是那些在出问题之前谁都不会真正去想的基础设施。当你的城市里有什么东西坏了，比如坏掉的路灯或坑洼，你可以打 311，提交一份报告，然后城市希望会把它修好。但如果你想了解你的城市是如何真正运作的，这就是本节目切入的地方。把我们想象成播客界的 311。我们希望你向我们发送关于基础设施的问题，然后我们将对其进行调查，并希望能找出答案。对于我们的第一期节目，我们有来自克里斯托弗的这个服务请求。311 究竟是如何运作的？
Because it turns out the system you use to report problems and complaints is its own kind of infrastructure. One that has quietly changed how cities across the country actually work. I'm so embarrassed to talk about this now, but like I went full tilt, Karen. Let's stick with Christopher's story for a moment. When Mr. Softie got to be too much, he started Googling. And he discovered a law that had been passed about 20 years ago that said ice cream trucks had to turn off their jingles when they were idling or stopped.
因为事实证明，你用来报告问题和投诉的系统本身就是一种基础设施。一种悄然改变全国各大城市实际运作方式的基础设施。现在说起这个我感到非常尴尬，但我当时简直就是个彻头彻尾的“卡伦”（Karen）。让我们暂时回到克里斯托弗的故事。当“软冰淇淋先生”变得实在让人无法忍受时，他开始上网搜索。他发现了一条大约20年前通过的法律，该法律规定冰淇淋车在怠速或停下时必须关掉它们的叮咚音乐。
When you park, you have to turn that shit off. And I was like, I got you, Mr. Softie, because they were not doing that. They were full on, like, posting up on the corners below my apartment for a half hour. long time and Mr. Softy jingle time. Absolutely. That's how many repetitions of the jingle? Probably like, what? 500? Hundreds. Hundreds. Absolutely. But who's counting? Hundreds.
当你停车时，你必须把那破玩意儿关掉。当时我就想，我抓到你了，“软冰淇淋先生”，因为他们根本没有那样做。他们完全就像是，在我公寓楼下的街角一停就是半个小时。很长的时间，还有“软冰淇淋先生”的叮咚音乐时间。绝对是的。那是重复了多少次叮咚音乐？大概，什么？500次？几百次。几百次。绝对是的。但谁在数呢？几百次。
This was the moment when Christopher decided to call 311. He figured he had something real to report. Mr. Softie was breaking the law and he wanted the city to do something about it. And what do you remember about the call? Just take me through it. as much as you can remember. I remember that you get a greeting, and initially they try to kind of, you know, if it's this issue, go this way. If it's that issue, go that way.
这就是克里斯托弗决定拨打 311 的时刻。他觉得自己有真正的事情要举报。“软冰淇淋先生”在违法，他希望市政府对此采取行动。关于那个电话，你还记得什么？带我过一遍，尽可能多地回忆。我记得你会听到一句问候，起如果是这个问题，请走这边。如果是那个问题，请走那边。
And at first I thought, of course, there's no real person that's going to pick this up. And I was like, okay, this is classic. I'm being routed down a kind of like to a dead end. Yeah. But I hung on and someone picks up. Like a real person. A real person, a real live person. sounds like a New Yorker, New York accent, you know, very friendly, like, ready to help.
起初我想，当然了，不会有真人来接听这个。当时我想，好吧，这很经典。我被引导走向了一条死胡同。是的。但我坚持了下来，有人接听了。就像个真人。一个真人，一个活生生的真人。听起来像个纽约客，有纽约口音，你知道的，非常友好，就像是准备好提供帮助。
And they ask me questions like, of course, what is the complaint? And I tell them that, you know, at this point, the Mr. Softie, the ice cream truck, keeps pulling up. Right. What they do then is they ask you these, like, very specific questions. That's one of the things I remember is that they're like, which days of the week, Sunday through Saturday? And I'm like every single day. And then they say around what time. Best case scenario, they're trying to figure out when they're going to send someone to try to catch this in this ice cream truck in the act.
他们问我一些问题，比如，当然了，投诉是什么？我告诉他们，你知道的，在这个时候，“软冰淇淋先生”，那个冰淇淋车，一直在开过来。没错。他们随后做的是问你这些，非常具体的问题。我记得的一件事是，他们会问，一周中的哪几天，星期日到星期六？我说每一天。然后他们会问大约什么时间。在最佳情况下，他们试图弄清楚他们什么时候会派人去试图当场抓获这辆冰淇淋车。
And your sense is that it's probably to dispatch someone to ticket, perhaps, the ice cream truck. That's right. Okay, okay, got it. Christopher made his complaint. The operator took his details. and then he waited to see if anything would happen next. And as he waited, he started wondering what happens on the other side of the phone when someone calls 3-1-1. That's when we come back.
你的感觉是，这可能是为了派人去给冰淇淋车开罚单，也许吧？没关系，好吧，明白了。克里斯托弗进行了投诉。接线员记录了他的详细信息。然后他等待着看看接下来是否会发生什么。当他等待时，他开始好奇当有人拨打 311 时，电话的另一端会发生什么。这就是我们回来时要讲的。
To start, we'll go back to the days before 3-1-1. In the 1980s and 90s, 3-1 did not exist in New York. In fact, it didn't exist anywhere in the country. And when people had issues, even mundane ones like potholes or noise complaints, they were calling 911. In some places like Baltimore, about 60% of 911 calls were for non-emergencies, and it was totally gumming up the system. Weight times were growing and real emergencies were getting lost in the noise.
首先，我们要回到没有 311 的日子。在 20 世纪 80 年代和 90 年代，纽约并没有 311。事实上，全国任何地方都没有。当人们遇到问题时，甚至是像道路坑洼或噪声投诉这样平凡的问题，他们都在拨打 911。在巴尔的摩等一些地方，大约 60% 的 911 呼叫都是非紧急情况，这彻底堵塞了系统。等待时间越来越长，真正的紧急情况在噪音中迷失了。
And so in 1996, Baltimore officials launched the first 311 in the country to take the pressure off of their overwhelmed 911 lines. A few years later, Chicago started its own 3-1-1 service, and then Houston. These early systems were pretty simple. They were basically just call centers that could route you to the right department. But when Michael Bloomberg was elected the mayor of New York City in 2001, he had bigger ambitions. He had the vision of taking the 3-1 apparatus and really expanding it into that full-scale customer service operation. This is Joseph Morris Row. He's been in charge of 311 in New York City since 2006.
因此，在 1996 年，巴尔的摩官员推出了全国第一个 311，以减轻他们不堪重负的 911 线路的压力。几年后，芝加哥启动了自己的 311 服务，接着是休斯顿。这些早期系统非常简单。它们基本上只是呼叫中心，可以将你转接到正确的部门。但当迈克尔·布隆伯格（Michael Bloomberg）于 2001 年当选纽约市长时，他有着更大的野心。他设想将 311 机构真正扩展为全面规模的客户服务运营。这是约瑟夫·莫里斯罗（Joseph Morris Row）。他自 2006 年以来一直负责纽约市的 311。
I believe I have the best job in all of New York City. Better than the rat czar? Better than the rats are, who we work closely with. Michael Bloomberg wanted New York's 311 to handle pretty much any question or complaint a New Yorker could dream up, way beyond what other cities were doing. The idea for New York City was, if 311 is going to be the central point, we need it to be for everything. So it wasn't just infrastructure calls or questions about what day is my recycle and what day is my sanitation pickup. But if it was a need for homeless services, if you needed
我相信我拥有全纽约市最好的工作。比老鼠沙皇（rat czar）还带劲？比老鼠沙皇还好，我们与他们密切合作。迈克尔·布隆伯格希望纽约的 311 能够处理纽约客能想到的几乎任何问题或投诉，远超其他城市当时的做法。纽约市的想法是，如果 311 要成为中心点，我们需要它是万能的。所以它不仅是基础设施电话或关于我的回收日是哪一天、我的环卫清运日是哪一天的问题。而且如果需要无家可归者服务，如果你需要
food assistance, we needed to have that information in our system and also have customers call us to be able to get that information. That sounds like a huge task just on the back end, like getting ready to open a call center that can answer any call that comes in from a citizen. And before you could start answering the public's questions, the city had to do the work of organizing all of that information themselves. Do you know how they went about that? You actually just kind of recap the first year of work by a large number of people. There was no large call center in New York City at that time. Different agencies, as we call them here, may have had their own call center.
食品援助，我们需要将这些信息纳入我们的系统中，并让客户打电话给我们以获取这些信息。单在后端这听起来就是一项巨大的任务，就像准备开设一个呼叫中心，能够接听来自市民的任何呼叫。在你开始回答公众的问题之前，这座城市必须自己完成所有这些信息的组织工作。你知道他们是怎么着手的吗？你实际上只是在回顾一大群人第一年的工作。当时纽约市没有大型呼叫中心。我们这里所说的不同机构，可能拥有自己的呼叫中心。
The Department of Transportation may have had people who answered the phones, and the Department of Sanitation had a group of folks who took calls from the public. But there was no large call center. So to solve that problem, the first take was we will consolidate all of them, not just pull the people in, but also put it into one single location. The team also had to build the software for accepting and tracking calls. And most dauntingly, they had to assemble every piece of information New Yorkers might possibly ask about, and then cram it all into a searchable database for the operators.
交通局可能有人接听电话，环卫局也有一群人负责接听公众来电。但没有大型呼叫中心。因此，为了解决这个问题，第一步是我们将所有这些机构整合起来，不仅是把人集中起来，还要把它们放在一个单一的地点。团队还必须构建用于接受和追踪电话的软件。最令人畏惧的是，他们必须收集纽约客可能提出的每一个问题，然后将它们全部塞进一个供接线员搜索的数据库中。
And they pulled all that information into a knowledge management database, which then allowed, you know, the agent handling the call to access that new system, that new CRM system, to do a search, very similar to a Google search now. And then, boom, they had the answer to the question. And they're able to give that answer to the customer. Wow. You're describing it as, you know, a database or a content management system. And I'm thinking of it as like this Bible of everything you could possibly know about New York City. And it's amazing to think about the scope of that.
他们将所有这些信息汇集到一个知识管理数据库中，这随后允许，你知道的，处理呼叫的代理访问那个新系统，那个新 CRM 系统，进行搜索，与现在的谷歌搜索非常相似。然后，轰的一下，他们就有了问题的答案。并且他们能够将该答案提供给客户。哇。你把它描述为，你知道的，一个数据库或内容管理系统。而我把它想象成一本关于你对纽约市可能了解的一切的圣经。想到它的规模，真是令人惊叹。
It really is. NYC 311 launched on March 9, 2003. The first call to come in was a noise complaint from Jackson Heights, Queens. And soon, Bloomberg was hyping the new hotline everywhere he went. If you want to know how to register your child for school, call 311. Want to know what time the bus will pick up and drop off your child? Call 311. You can also cool off at one of the city's public beaches.
确实如此。纽约市 311 于 2003 年 3 月 9 日正式上线。打进的第一个电话是来自皇后区杰克逊高地（Jackson Heights）的噪声投诉。不久之后，布隆伯格在他去过的任何地方都在大肆宣传这条新热线。如果你想知道如何为你的孩子办理入学登记，请拨打 311。想知道校车什么时候接送你的孩子？请拨打 311。你还可以在该市的公共海滩纳凉。
For the location and hours of the nearest beach, all you've got to do is dial. 311. 311 has helped more than 216,000 New Yorkers find resources to stop smoking. These days, New York's 311 receives more than 17 million calls a year, along with millions of contacts by text and through their website and their app. The call center is staffed 24 hours a day, seven days a week, by operators waiting to take your questions and complaints. One of them is Samantha Pierce. So take us through how do you answer the phone and what do you ask? Right. So there's a standard greeting. Thank you for calling 311. My name is Samantha. How can I assist you? Samantha was born and raised in New York City and she's been working with 311 since 2013.
有关最近海滩的位置和营业时间，你只需拨打。311。311 已经帮助超过 21.6 万名纽约客找到了戒烟资源。如今，纽约的 311 每年接到超过 1700 万通电话，以及通过短信、网站和应用程序进行的数百万次联络。该呼叫中心由接线员全天候 7 天值班，等待接听您的提问和投诉。其中一位是萨曼莎·皮尔斯（Samantha Pierce）。那么请带我们了解一下你是如何接听电话的以及你会问什么？好的。所以有一个标准的问候语。感谢致电 311。我是萨曼莎。有什么我可以帮您的？萨曼莎在纽约市出生长大，她自 2013 年起就在 311 工作。
She says that the first thing a caller will encounter is an interactive voice response system, an IVR. That's the menu that Christopher navigated when he called with his Mr. Softie complaint. It basically figured out where to direct his call. And that means that once he ended up with an operator, they probably had a pretty good sense of what he was calling
她说，来电者遇到的第一件事就是交互式语音应答系统，即 IVR。那是克里斯托弗在带着他的“软冰淇淋先生”投诉打电话时浏览的菜单。它基本上弄清楚了该把他的电话转到哪里。这意味着一旦他联系上接线员，他们可能对他的来电内容有了相当好的了解
about. It just kind of helps smooth out the call of it and gets the agent on the role. Another thing that's really cool about the system is that when that topic populates, it'll take that agent to the information that they need related to that
这有助于顺畅通话，让代理迅速进入角色。关于该系统的另一个非常酷的地方是，当那个主题弹出时，它会将代理带到他们与该主题相关的信息
topic. So it kind of gets a jumpstart on finding what the customer needs. Noise complaints often top the list of issues that people call about, followed by illegal parking and questions about heat and hot water. But knowing the broad strokes of the issue is not enough for the operators. When we train our agents, we train them to probe because our system is not set up like Google, right? You go on the Google and you type in a topic and it's going to give you what you need.
因此，它有助于快速找到客户需要的东西。噪声投诉通常位居人们来电反映问题列表的前列，其次是违章停车以及关于暖气和热水的咨询。但是，仅了解问题的总体情况对接线员来说是不够的。当我们培训我们的代理时，我们培训他们去深入探究，因为我们的系统不像谷歌那样，对吧？你上谷歌，输入一个主题，它就会给你你需要的东西。
We need to know the what, but we need to know the what. But really, our system is based on the why. So if you call in and you say, hey, I need to talk to the Department of Finance about this parking ticket I received, that's not going to be enough for the agent to assist. What exactly do you need? Why do you need to speak to them? What is the issue with the parking ticket? We need to get to the why, and that's really how our system is navigated. I mean, I got to get a little nosy sometimes.
我们需要知道是什么，但我们需要知道是什么。但实际上，我们的系统是基于为什么的。所以如果你打进来并说，嘿，我需要和财务部谈谈我收到的这张罚单，这还不足以让代理提供帮助。你到底需要什么？你为什么需要跟他们通话？罚单有什么问题？我们需要追溯到为什么，这确实是我们系统导航的方式。我的意思是，有时我不得不变得有点多管闲事。
And, you know, that's just the way our system is set up. And it's not like you're just following a script. You have to be on your toes interacting with a real human being who has a problem and figuring out what the root of it is. Absolutely. And then another thing that's really important is that a lot of people are not happy for good reason. When I coach my team, I tell them, you know, the empathy is so important because if you had sewage coming into your basement, you'd be a little upset as well. And when they answer that phone, I tell them they are the city, right? They might have a complaint about Department of Sanitation or Department of Finance, whatever the case is. They don't get to speak directly to those agencies. They're speaking to you. And in that moment, sometimes unfairly, you might get the brunt of their frustration.
而且，你知道的，这就是我们系统的运作方式。而且这不像你只是在遵循剧本。你必须随机应变，与一个有问题的真实人类互动，并弄清楚问题的根源是什么。绝对是的。然后另一件非常重要的事情是，许多人有充分的理由感到不高兴。当我指导我的团队时，我告诉他们，你知道的，同理心非常重要，因为如果你的地下室涌入了污水，你也会有点心烦意乱。当他们接听那个电话时，我告诉他们他们代表了这座城市，对吧？他们可能对环卫局或财务局有投诉，无论情况如何。他们无法直接与这些机构对话。他们在跟你对话。而在那一刻，有时是不公平的，你可能会承受他们挫败感的大部分怒火。
But if you help them to the best of your ability, by the end of the call, they're grateful. And so what do you want the voice of the city to sound like? I want the voice of the city to be number one helpful, accurate and familiar because we are not outsourced. We're in New York City and most of us are from New York City. We know New York because we are New York. And I think that translates to how we service New York. Right. Okay, so you get one of these calls. You got to make sure people are sort of calm down enough give you the information that you need. You figure out what's actually going on with them.
但如果你尽你所能帮助他们，到通话结束时，他们会心存感激。那么，你希望城市的嗓音听起来像什么？我希望城市的嗓音排在第一位的是乐于助人、准确且熟悉，因为我们不是外包的。我们在纽约市，我们大多数人来自纽约市。我们了解纽约，因为我们就是纽约。我认为这转化为了我们服务纽约的方式。好的，所以你接到其中一通电话。你得确保人们足够冷静，能提供你需要的信息。你弄清楚他们身上到底发生了什么。
What happens next? How do you route that call? Okay, so the main method, I think, for reporting customers' issues is through service requests, where a lot of them are preset, meaning you're just clicking on this customer wants to report a pothole. They'll click it in the sheet or the service request. It's already preset.
接下来会发生什么？你如何转接那个电话？好的，所以主要的方针，我认为，对于报告客户问题是通过服务请求，其中许多是预设的，这意味着你只需点击这位客户想要报告一个路坑。他们会在表格或服务请求中点击它。它是预设的。
So you're really just filling in, you know, information. Once we send those off, they go automatically to the responding agency. The responding agency determines how long it's going to take to fix said issue. Once the service request was submitted, the customer gets what's called a service request number, and that allows them to track the progress of their complaint. Got it. Okay. There was this report that came out a few years ago about 311 with a section about memorable calls. And just to read a few of those allowed, you know, someone said, I'd like to file a noise complaint against my refrigerator, or can I claim my dog as a dependent on my taxes, or I would like to report a ghost in my window.
所以你实际上只是在填入，你知道的，信息。一旦我们把这些发出去，它们就会自动发送给响应机构。响应机构决定修复所述问题需要多长时间。一旦服务请求提交，客户就会得到一个所谓的服务请求号码，这使他们能够追踪其投诉的进展。明白了。好吧。几年前有一份关于 311 的报告，其中有一个关于难忘电话的部分。只是大声朗读其中几个，你知道的，有人说，我想对我的冰箱提出噪声投诉，或者我可以把我的狗作为家属申报税收抵免吗，或者我想举报我窗户上的鬼魂。
Can you tell me about some of the maybe strangest or most memorable 311 calls you've received? I remember when I was a call taker, there was a customer that was reporting that her downstairs neighbor was sending vibrations into her apartment. And she was adamant and really insisted. And this is the thing, right? You're supposed to take the calls at face value. Right. So you can't say, that's not happening. What are you talking about? You can't say that. You have to do your best to try to figure out, hey, maybe it could be this. Like, is there something going on with the building? Is it like an unstable foundation? Once you rule out like kind of the real solutions that we have, you kind of have to just be honest with the customer and say, I don't think that we can take a report for it. And, you know,
你能跟我讲讲你接到过的也许最奇怪或最难忘的一些 311 电话吗？我记得自我担任接线员以来，有一位客户报告说她楼下的邻居正在向她的公寓发送振动。而且她非常坚决，真的很坚持。这就是事情的所在，对吧？你应该按字面意思接受这些电话。对吧。所以你不能说，这没有发生。你在说什么？你不能那么做。你必须尽你所能去弄清楚，嘿，也许可能是这样的。比如，大楼有什么不对劲吗？是不是像地基不稳？一旦你排除了我们拥有的那种真正的解决方案，你基本上就不得不对客户诚实地说，我认为我们无法为此做记录。而且，你知道，
where the vibrations your neighbor is beaming to you from below. Right. Like there's no agency that handles mysterious vibrations. Right. Exactly. Not, yeah. They might be working on it. I'm not sure.
你邻居从下面向你发射的振动在哪里。对吧？就像没有哪个机构处理神秘振动一样。对吧？完全正确。没有，是的。他们可能正在研究。我不确定。
And then on a more serious note, I'm curious what kind of calls are like the hardest to take, whether that's emotionally or logistically. I think the hardest calls to take are, just related to the complexities or the challenges of New York City living, like the competitive housing market and people calling and saying, like, I legitimately can't afford to leave or live here. Like, what do you do with that? I think that that's a more serious topic in terms of people that are really trying to find
然后从更严肃的角度来看，我很好奇哪类电话最难接听，无论是从情感上还是后勤上。我认为最难接听的电话是，只与纽约市生活的复杂性或挑战有关，比如竞争激烈的住房市场，人们打电话说，我真的负担不起离开或住在这里的费用。你会对那种情况做什么？我认为就那些真正试图找到负担得起的、安全居住地的人而言，这是一个更严肃的话题
an affordable, safe place to live. Right. But there's just also, there's always like day-to-day challenges of New York City. It's a noisy place. Some people don't do well with that. It can kind of get to you sometimes. Those calls always, they kind of leave you a little sad. New York City is a noisy place.
对吧。但除此之外，纽约市总是有日常的挑战。这是一个嘈杂的地方。有些人对这不太适应。有时它确实会影响到你。这些电话总是，它们会让你有点悲伤。纽约市是一个嘈杂的地方。
That brings us back to Christopher. He made his Mr. Softie complaints anonymously, like a coward. And so he never got a service request number, which means we can't actually track what happened to his specific complaint. What we do know is that it would have likely been routed to the Department of Environmental Protection, the agency responsible for mitigating noise pollution. I also went digging around on the 311 website to better understand noise complaints, and honestly, I was kind of amazed by what I found.
这把我们带回了克里斯托弗。他匿名投诉了“软冰淇淋先生”，就像个懦夫一样。所以他从未拿到过服务请求号码，这意味着我们无法实际追踪他的具体投诉发生了什么。我们所知道的是，它很可能已被转交给环境保护局，该机构负责减轻噪声污染。我还去 311 网站上搜寻，以更好地了解噪声投诉，老实说，我对我的发现感到有点惊讶。
311 has created this incredibly specific taxonomy of annoying sounds. You can report air conditioners, alarms, banging, pounding, and moving furniture, which is its own category. There's boilers, construction, dogs, leaf blowers, music, televisions, fireworks, generators, houses of worship, parks, pools, and beaches.
311 创建了一个令人难以置信的、针对烦人声音的具体分类法。你可以举报空调、警报声、砰砰声、重击声以及搬动家具（它有自己的分类）。还有锅炉、建筑工程、狗、吹叶机、音乐、电视、烟花、发电机、宗教场所、公园、游泳池和海滩。
And if you scroll way, way down to the end of the list, you'll find ice cream trucks. Which clearly means that Christopher is not the only person in New York afflicted by Mr. Softie. To me, there's something incredible about this list. It's like the city has somehow managed to catalog every possible way that people drive each other crazy.
如果你一直向下滚动到列表的底部，你会发现冰淇淋车。这显然意味着克里斯托弗并不是纽约唯一一个受到“软冰淇淋先生”折磨的人。对我来说，这个列表有一些不可思议的地方。就像这座城市不知何故设法编纂了人们互相逼疯的每一种可能方式。
Every grievance is accounted for. It makes me think that the way 311 operators see the city is just different. Oh, oh yeah, definitely. I have a deeper understanding, I guess, of how things work here. I have a deeper understanding and appreciation for just city planning. But beyond that, just you start to see things and you immediately feel. think about what you would be putting in the system to fix it. Like I remember about five years ago,
每一个怨气都被考虑到了。这让我觉得 311 接线员看待这座城市的方式就是不同。哦，哦是的，绝对的。我想我对这里的事情是如何运作的有了更深入的了解。我对城市规划有了更深的理解和欣赏。不仅如此，你开始看到各种事情，并且你会立刻感觉到。考虑你会把什么放入系统中来修复它。就像我大约五年前记得的，
there was a really specific process for disposing of electronics, like specifically televisions. You couldn't just put them out with your regular trash. So I remember my husband and I were walking and I saw like a tube TV just sitting in front of someone's property. I said, oh my goodness, what are they doing? You can't put that there. And I went down this whole description.
处理电子产品（特别是电视机）有一个非常具体的流程。你不能只把它们和你的普通垃圾一起扔出去。所以我记得我和丈夫在散步时，我看到一台老式显像管电视机正放在某人的物业前面。我说，哦天哪，他们在干什么？你不能把那个放在那儿。我经历了一整套描述
of what you had to do and what the penalty, this person is going to get a ticket. Why would they do this? And I look over at my husband, he's just staring at me. Like, what? You're really passionate about these TVs. That was about, I would say, maybe four years ago. And as recently as last week, he will call me and say, hey, you know, I saw a TV sitting outside of this house. Like, what are you going to do about it?
你必须做什么以及罚款是什么，这个人会吃到一张罚单。他们为什么要做这种事？我看着我丈夫，他只是盯着我。就像，什么？你对这些电视真的很有热情。那是大约，我可以说，大概四年前。就在上周，他还会打电话给我说，嘿，你知道的，我看到一台电视机放在这栋房子的外面。比如，你打算怎么处理它？
Because he knows I was really bothered by people. Why aren't you following the process? Call 311 so you can find out what to do with this TV. So, yeah, that's the lens that I look at. the city through just hey how can I fix this that is so funny like to walk through your neighborhood just knowing like I know who handles that right who handles that right should not be doing that exactly it's like you sort of have this code this city code you know right and then I am the 3-1-1 for my friends and family sometimes I don't like to tell people that I work here just because
因为他知道我真的很讨厌人们。为什么不遵循流程？打 311，这样你就能弄清楚怎么处理这台电视。所以，是的，这就是我审视这座城市的镜头，只是嘿，我怎么能解决这个问题？这太有趣了，就像走过你的社区，只知道——我认识处理那个的人，谁处理那个——不应该那样做，对吧？准确地说。就像你有点拥有这个代码，这个城市代码，你知道的，对吧，然后我是我的朋友和家人的 311 有时我不喜欢告诉别人我在这里工作只是因为
they're going to text you and call you and ask you questions all the time and while I remember a lot of the stuff. There's 7,000 different individual pieces of information. I don't have everything retained to my memory. Oh, that's so funny. Samantha, thank you so much. I love hearing about your experiences as an operator. And I'm so impressed with the scope of what New York does. So, thank you for telling us about your work. Sure. Thank you so much for having me. It was a pleasure, Delaney. So nice to meet you. When we come back, we'll look at what happens when someone calls with a question, and 311 does not have the answer. When 311 launched in 2003, its database had about a thousand discrete pieces of information
他们会给你发短信、打电话，一直问你问题，虽然我记得很多东西。有 7000 个不同的单项信息。我没有把所有东西都记在脑子里。哦，太有趣了。萨曼莎，非常感谢你。我很高兴听到你作为接线员的经历。我对纽约市的工作范围印象深刻。所以，谢谢你告诉我们你的工作。当然。非常感谢邀请我。这是我的荣幸，德兰妮。很高兴认识你。当我们回来时，我们将看看当有人打电话询问问题而 311 没有答案时会发生什么。当 311 在 2003 年推出时，其数据库大约有一千个独立的关于城市运作方式的信息片段
about the way the city works. Today, there are more than 7,000, and I wanted to know how new information ends up in the system. Joe Morrisrow, the deputy commissioner in charge of 311, told me a story that helped illustrate how it happens. Just a few months after 311, just a few months after 311 got up and running, the city was hit with a massive blackout. It has been more than 12 hours now since the power went out here in New York City. They called Times Square the crossroads of the world. Tonight, it is the crossroads of darkness. Conductors just sit with the whole system down.
今天，有超过 7000 个，我想知道新信息是如何最终进入系统的。负责 311 的副专员乔·莫里斯罗（Joe Morrisrow）给我讲了一个故事，有助于说明它是如何发生的。就在 311 刚成立几个月后，就在 311 刚投入运行几个月后，这座城市遭遇了一场大停电。纽约市停电已经超过12个小时了。他们称时代广场为世界的十字路口。今晚，它是黑暗的十字路口。售票员只能坐着，整个系统都瘫痪了。
How long have you been waiting to move your train? 22 hours. The blackout affected close to 50 million people across the northeastern U.S. and parts of Canada, making it one of the largest power outages in North America. history. Needless to say, 311 got a lot of calls, and some of them were unexpected. My understanding is that power was out across the city. People's refrigerators weren't working, and people with diabetes started calling into 311 to ask, how do I preserve my insulin? Yeah, it's a true story. We've actually had a few of those over the years where you get an unexpected,
你等著挪动火车有多久了？22个小时。这场停电影响了美国东北部和部分加拿大的近5000万人，使其成为北美历史上最大规模的停电事故之一。不用说，311 接到了很多电话，其中一些是出乎意料的。我的理解是整个城市都停电了。人们的冰箱无法运转，患有糖尿病的人开始打电话给 311 询问，我该如何保存我的胰岛素？是的，这是一个真实的故事。多年来我们实际上经历过几次这样的事情，你会遇到意想不到的、
unanticipated impact that you hadn't thought of. But the call came in and there's a process. If you don't have an answer to a question, you bring it to your supervisor. Your supervisor brings it to our, we call it our content team. They go research it. We also have contacts at every city agency
你没有想到的出乎意料的影响。但电话打进来了，有一个流程。如果你对某个问题没有答案，你把它带给你的主管。你的主管把它带到我们的，我们称之为我们的内容团队。他们去研究它。我们还与每个城市机构都有联系
that are dedicated to working with 3-1-1. So that question went from an agent to a supervisor to a staff person who then got a whole of the Department of Health said, we need guidance on this. The Department of Health quickly researched the answer, and Bloomberg announced it at a press conference. Insulin can stay at room temperature for 28 days. And this whole experience showed that 311 had created something genuinely new, a feedback loop, where citizens could tell the city what they needed, and the city could actually respond. Joe shared another moment like this one from 311's history.
致力于与 311 合作。所以这个问题从代理传给主管，再传给工作人员，然后联系了卫生局，说，我们需要关于这个的指导。卫生局迅速研究了答案，布隆伯格在新闻发布会上宣布了这一消息。胰岛素可以在室温下保存 28 天。整个经历表明，311 创造了一些真正崭新的东西，一个反馈回路，市民可以告诉城市他们需要什么，而城市实际上可以做出回应。乔分享了 311 历史上的另一个这样的时刻。
It happened in 2009 when an airplane taking off from LaGuardia ran into a flock of geese and had to crash land on the Hudson River. The whole thing became known as the miracle on the Hudson, because everyone survived the crash. There's been a plane crash here in New York City, and right now you're looking at live pictures of a U.S. Airways jetliner that went down in the Hudson River. When it hit the Hudson River, it just looked like a volcano exploded. Everyone on board, 155 people make it out alive. As the whole thing was unfolding, the team at 311 was fielding all kinds of calls. People wanted to know what had happened and if everyone was okay. Probably around 7 o'clock that night we finally felt like, okay, we get everything good, everything's under control, we can leave for the night.
它发生在 2009 年，当时一架从拉瓜迪亚（LaGuardia）起飞的飞机撞上了一群大雁，不得不迫降在哈德逊河上。整件事被称为哈德逊河奇迹，因为机上所有人都从坠机中幸存下来。纽约市发生了一场飞机失事，现在你们看到的是一架全美航空喷气式客机在哈德逊河坠毁的实况画面。当它撞击哈德逊河时，看起来就像是一座火山爆发了。机上所有人，155人全部生还。随着整件事情的发酵，311的团队正在处理各种各样的电话。人们想知道发生了什么以及每个人是否都安好。大概在当晚7点左右，我们终于觉得，好吧，我们把一切都处理好了，一切都在控制之中，我们可以下班回家了。
All of a sudden we get a message from a colleague at City Hall that people are calling to say, how do I get my luggage from the plane? and luggage was washing up downstream on New York and New Jersey side. So we quickly, we had literally had people leaving. We pulled them back in. They started going through finding out how we could do it. The New York City Emergency Management Office came up with the plan on how they could collect it. And we put content in our system to tell people what to do and where to go if they needed to find their luggage or if they were finding luggage washing up ashore. Where should they take it?
突然，我们收到市政厅一位同事的消息，说人们打电话来问，我怎么从飞机上拿回我的行李？而且行李正顺流而上被冲上纽约和新泽西一侧的岸边。所以我们迅速——我们真的有员工要下班了。我们把他们拉了回来。他们开始研究我们该怎么做。纽约市应急管理局提出了如何收集行李的计划。我们在系统中添加了内容，告诉人们如果需要找行李或者发现行李被冲上岸该怎么做、去哪里。他们应该把行李带到哪里？
Who should they give it to? Amazing. Wow. To this day, anytime we have an event that's known, a known event, weather event in particular, we do what we call a checklist. And we go through everything that's on our plan and we try to come up with everything that's not in our plan before we kind of call it ready. And ever since that day, we call it floating luggage. So we always end the meeting with what's the floating luggage that we haven't thought about yet
他们应该把它交给谁？太棒了。哇。直到今天，每当发生我们所知道的事件，特别是已知的气象事件时，我们都会做我们称之为清单的事情。我们过一遍计划中的所有事情，在我们认为准备就绪之前，我们试图想出计划中没有的一切。从那一天起，我们就把这叫做漂浮行李。所以我们总是以会议结束：还有什么是我们没想到的可能会出现的漂浮行李？
that may come up. Oh, man. And so it's just become this term that prompts you guys to think, okay, there's got to be something that's that we're going to have to answer that we haven't thought about. And what could it be? Exactly. Today, the whole concept of 311 has spread. About 300 cities and counties nationwide now have 311 systems of their own. But New York has been a leader in making its 311 data public and used.
天哪。所以它只是变成了这样一个术语，促使你们思考，好吧，一定有什么东西是我们必须要回答的，而我们还没想到的。那会是什么？准确地说。如今，311 的整个概念已经普及。全国约有 300 个城市和县现在拥有自己的 311 系统。但纽约一直是将其 311 数据公开并以创新方式使用的领导者，将数百万条投诉转化为城市需求的实时地图。有一些关于 311 数据如何帮助这座城市的故事非常引人入胜。例如，早在 2000 年代中期，你在城里走着走着，那种奇怪的甜味，有点像煎饼的味道，就会扑面而来。这是人们会谈论的本地现象。比如，你昨晚闻到枫糖浆的味道了吗？那是什么？人们不断打电话给 311 举报。
it in novel ways, turning millions of complaints into a real-time map of what the city needs. And there are some fascinating stories about how 311 data helps the city. For example, back in the mid-2000s, you'd be walking around the city and this weird, sweet smell, kind of like pancakes, would just hit you. It was this local phenomenon that people would talk about. Like, did you smell the maple syrup last night? What is that? People kept calling 311 to report it.
然后检查人员会赶到现场试图弄清楚那是什么，但等他们到达时，气味已经消失了。我们已经解开了过去几年一直飘浮在我们城市部分地区的这种奇怪的、类似枫糖的异味的谜团。最终，城市绘制了关于这种气味的每一个 311 电话的地图，并将其与风向图叠加。事件发生时的风向通常是从西向东移动，这表明神秘气味的来源在新泽西州的哈德逊县（Hudson）或伯根县（Bergen）。
And then inspectors would show up to try and figure out what it was, but by the time they arrived, the smell was gone. We have solved the mystery of the strange maple sugar-like odor that has been wafting through parts of our city during the past few years. Eventually, the city mapped every 3-1-1 call about the smell and overlaid it with wind patterns. The winds at the time of the incident generally moving from west to east, indicating that the source of the mysterious odor was in Hudson or Bergen counties in New Jersey.
他们找到了罪魁祸首。那是新泽西州的一家工厂，加工胡芦巴种子，闻起来很像枫糖浆。这让纽约客有机会感到沾沾自喜。当然，奇怪的神秘气味来自他们的邻居——有人会说这个邻居不那么迷人，一个以奇怪的工业气味而闻名的州。综合考虑，我能想到很多比枫糖浆更糟糕的事情。所以我们正式结案了。我在思考人工智能和聊天机器人的演变，以及为什么当你拨打客服电话时，你越来越多地不是在与人类互动。
And they figured out the culprit. It was a New Jersey factory processing Fenugreek seeds, which smell a lot like maple syrup. This gave New Yorkers a chance to feel smug. Of course, the weird mystery smell was coming from their, some would say, less glamorous neighbor, a state known for its weird industrial smells. All things considered, I can think of a lot of things worse than maple syrup. So we are officially closing the case. I'm thinking about the evolution of AI and chatbots and how increasingly when you call customer service, you are not interacting with a human.
你在和一个聊天机器人交谈。我想知道这项技术是否会在未来十年改变 311。我们正在密切关注。我们已经在探索了。我们已经在测试了。人工智能将增强我们的工作。就像从呼叫中心到在线存在、再到移动应用程序、再到短信存在的演变一样。未来将会有AI元素。
You're talking with a chatbot. And I wonder if that technology is going to change 311 in the coming decade. We're looking at that closely. We're already exploring. We're already testing. AI is going to augment what we do. And much like the evolution from a call center to a online presence, to a mobile app, to text presence. There'll be an AI element in the future.
所以我们总会有选择。纽约客能够打电话与另一个纽约客交谈，这本身就有一种美妙之处，你知道的，而且我认为如果是自动化系统，就会失去一些东西。我认为你说得对，不仅有人与代理交谈的那个元素，而且在我们的案例中，它确实是这样的。这是一个拥有纽约风格、纽约节奏、纽约脉搏和纽约需求的纽约客，在与他们的社区成员交谈，一个可能住在同一个街区、当然可能住在同一个区或同一个城市的人，他理解他们在寻找什么，并且能够帮助他们，因为他们拥有工具、技术和承诺。
So we'll always have options. there's something sort of beautiful about a New Yorker being able to call and talk to another New Yorker, you know, and I think something would be lost if it was an automated system. I think you're right when you say there's always that element of not only someone talking to an agent, but in our case, it really is that. It is a New Yorker who has a New York kind of beat and a New York pulse and a New York need talking to one of their community members, someone who may live in the same neighborhood, certainly may live in the same borough or the same city, who understands what they're looking for and is able to help them because they have the tools and they have the technology and they have the commitment.
我认为这一切把它们凝聚在了一起。好的，乔，非常感谢你抽出时间。听到这项服务是如何诞生的，真是太棒了。哦，不客气，非常欢迎。我很感激这个机会。正如你所能猜到的，我期待谈论 311。所以我很高兴这样做。
And I think it all pulls that together. Right. Well, Joe, thank you so much for your time. It's been just great to hear about how this service came to be. Oh, you're very, very welcome. I appreciate the opportunity. As you probably guess, I look forward to talking about 3-1-1. So I'm happy to do that.
所以我为此感谢你。我们从克里斯托弗的问题开始：311 实际上是如何运作的？我们得到了答案。至少，算是吧。当纽约市在 2003 年推出 311 时，官员们汇编了一个庞大的数据库，里面包含了关于城市运作方式的信息。
So I thank you for that. We started with Christopher's question. How does 3-1-1 actually work? And we've got an answer. At least, sort of. When New York City launched 3-1 in 2003, officials compiled a massive database of information about how the city works.
当你打电话、发短信或使用应用程序时，你的请求会生成一个服务工单，该工单会被转接到处理该问题的任何城市机构。从那时起，这就是他们的责任。以数百万请求形式生成的所有数据都被追踪、绘制和分析，以帮助这座城市了解纽约客真正的需求。至于克里斯托弗关于冰淇淋车的投诉，他告诉我们“软冰淇淋先生”不断地来，没完没了，而且他在打完 311 后没有注意到噪音有任何变化。最后，他找到了一个不同的解决方案。
When you call text or use the app, your request generates a service ticket that gets routed to whichever city agency handles that issue. And it's their responsibility from that point forward. All the data generated in the form of millions of requests gets tracked, mapped, and analyzed to help the city understand what New Yorkers actually need. As for Christopher's ice cream truck complaint, He tells us that the Mr. Softies kept coming around, relentlessly, and that he didn't notice any change in the noise after he called 311. In the end, he found a different solution.
当您打电话、发短信或使用该应用程序时，您的请求会生成一张服务单，并被分派给处理该问题的城市机构。从那时起，这就是他们的责任。以数百万次请求形式生成的所有数据都会被跟踪、绘制成地图并进行分析，以帮助该市了解纽约人实际需要什么。至于克里斯托弗对冰淇淋车的投诉，他告诉我们，美式冰淇淋车（Mr. Softies）不断地、无休止地开过来，而且他在拨打311后没有发现噪音有任何变化。最后，他找到了另一种解决方法。
He moved to Brooklyn. With that, consider your service request resolved. Today on the show, you heard Samantha Pierce, a supervisor at NYC 311. You also heard Joe Morris Row, the deputy commissioner at New York's Office of Technology and Innovation, and Christopher Johnson, senior ice cream truck hater at 99PI. What infrastructure mystery keeps you up at night? Something you use every day but don't actually understand. The card you swipe, the great you step over. If you're curious how it works, we want to know. Submit your service request by recording a voice memo with your question and emailing it to. service request at 99PI.org. To see a breakdown of last year's calls to NYC 311 and some of the most
他搬到了布鲁克林。至此，您的服务请求已解决。今天的节目中，您听到了纽约市311热线主管萨曼莎·皮尔斯的声音。您还听到了纽约市技术与创新办公室副专员乔·莫里斯·罗，以及99PI的高级冰淇淋车反对者克里斯托弗·约翰逊的声音。是什么基础设施谜团让你夜不能寐？有些东西你每天都在使用，但实际上并不了解。你刷的卡，你跨过的格栅。如果你好奇它是如何运作的，我们很想知道。请录制包含你问题的语音备忘录并发送电子邮件至 service request at 99PI.org 来提交你的服务请求。要查看去年拨打纽约市311热线的电话明细以及一些最
unusual complaints, find us on all the usual social media sites where we'll be sharing that information. And come hang out with a bunch of infrastructure nerds on the 99PI Discord. Remember, always consider the floating luggage. And if you think your neighbor is sending weird vibrations through your floor, you might be out of luck. In Delaney Hall, infrastructure is everywhere, and we're here to help you decode it. Service Request is a production of 99% Invisible and campside media. The show is produced and fact-checked by Julia K. Levine and edited by Shoshi Shmulevitz. Mix by Iwan Li Trimuwen.
寻常的投诉，请在各大常用社交媒体上关注我们，我们将会在那里分享这些信息。快来99PI的Discord上和一群基础设施极客一起交流吧。记住，永远考虑浮动的行李。如果你觉得你的邻居正在通过你的地板发送奇怪的振动，你可能就没那么走运了。在德莱尼大厅，基础设施无处不在，我们在这里帮助你解读它。Service Request 是 99% Invisible 和 Campside Media 共同制作的节目。该节目由朱莉娅·K·莱文制作和核实，由肖希·施穆列维茨剪辑。伊万·李·特里穆文混音。
Theme song and music by Swan Reall. Additional editing by Emmett Fitzgerald and Vivian Lay. Show art by Aaron Nestor. Roman Mars is our boss at 99PI. Kathy 2 is 99PI's executive producer. Matt Cher is the executive producer at Campside. We're part of the SiriusXM podcast family. You can find us on all the usual social media sites, as well as our Discord server.
主题曲和音乐由斯旺·里尔创作。艾米特·菲茨杰拉德和维维安·莱伊参与了额外剪辑。节目封面由亚伦·内斯特设计。罗曼·马尔斯是我们99PI的老板。凯茜·2是99PI的执行制片人。马特·切尔是Campside的执行制片人。我们是 SiriusXM 播客家族的一员。你可以在所有常用的社交媒体网站以及我们的 Discord 服务器上找到我们。
There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 99PI.org 上有通往该链接的通道，以及 99PI 过去的每一期节目。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可留下评论。